VQEのすべての要素を説明したところで、
学んだことをまとめ、量子コンピューターがどのように実行するかを見てみましょう。
まず、巧みに選んだ参照状態、パラメーター化されたcircuit、
パラメーターの初期値、そしてハミルトニアンから始めます。
これらを量子コンピューターに渡します。
ハミルトニアンをansatz状態で実行する前に、
circuitの古典的な前処理を行う必要があります。
これはトランスパイルと呼ばれる工程で、量子ハードウェアが読み取れる形に変換します。
また、最良の結果を得るために
実際のハードウェア上のqubitアーキテクチャを最大限に活用することも重要です。
これらの処理は多くの場合、自動的に行われるため、私たちが
qubitの接続性や
gateの忠実度などを明示的に意識する必要はありません。
次のタスクは、結果の状態を測定し、
期待値を推定することです。これはさらに
古典的なオプティマイザーによって最適化されます。
この測定は、測定基底を回転させることで行われます。
そして測定結果を組み合わせて期待値を求めます。
このパラメーター化された結果は、
古典的なオプティマイザーに渡され、状態の新しいパラメーターが求められます。
そして、このプロセスが繰り返されます。
古典的な前処理によって新しいパラメーター化されたcircuitが生成され、
先ほどと同じハミルトニアンを適用します。
VQEプロセス全体を通して変えるのは状態だけであり、
パラメーターを通じて基底状態へと少しずつ近づいていきます。
満足のいく結果が得られるまで、これを繰り返します。
以上です。
私はVictoria Lipinskaです。変分量子固有値ソルバーのコースでした。